[Música]
en afganistán el ejército británico
informó que siete civiles afganos
fallecieron durante una estampida cuando
una multitud intentaba ingresar al
aeropuerto de cabo las escenas de pánico
para huir del país se repiten desde hace
siete días cuando el talibán tomó
control del territorio los insurgentes
culpan a eeuu por el caos en la terminal
aérea
en eeuu el huracán y henri se mueve
hacia la costa en el sur de nueva
inglaterra y long island zona en la que
tocará tierra amenazado con fuertes
vientos de 120 kilómetros por hora una
marejada ciclónica y lluvias
torrenciales se emitieron alertas para
más de 42 millones de personas en la
región incluida la masiva ciudad de
nueva york
y son 2.200 muertos o 12.000 heridos y
al menos 300 desaparecidos en haití más
de una semana después del terremoto de
magnitud de 7.2 hay pocas esperanzas de
encontrar gente con vida entre los
escombros pero el equipo internacional
de rescate con los topos mexicanos a la
cabeza sigue en las tareas
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información internacional más
importante en france 24 7 personas
fallecieron durante una estampida a las
afueras del aeropuerto de kabul este
sábado y serían al menos 20 los decesos
totales desde hace una semana según
fuentes de la otan y es que multitudes
han intentado acceder a los aviones de
evacuación después de la caída del país
en manos del talibán el ejército
británico confirmó los siete decesos
washington es ya desaconsejó a los
afganos dirigirse al aeropuerto
entretanto el talibán avanza con sus
planes de formación de un nuevo gobierno
en el país sus comandantes se reunirán
con gobernadores de al menos 20 de las
34 provincias afganas en los próximos
días un portavoz de los insurgentes
responsabilizó a eeuu por el caos en la
terminal aérea de la capital
usted sabe que esas personas se están
reuniendo alrededor del aeropuerto
internacional de kabul
porque porque los estadounidenses les
dicen vengan aquí los llevamos a eeuu
con nosotros simplemente nombre un país
en el que la gente no haría eso si se
hiciera ese anuncio para el análisis
está con nosotros desde oslo noruega
mariano aguirre analista de cuestiones
internacionales y experto en geopolítica
mariano gracias y se cumplieron siete
días de la caída de afganistán una caída
que fue anunciada que fue mucho más
rápida de lo previsto
xavi a eeuu y la otan
del caos que iban a provocar después de
20 años de guerra los órganos están
completamente desprotegidos fue todo por
nada
no a eeuu y los aliados de la otan
básicamente se guiaron por sus servicios
de inteligencia y sus servicios de
inteligencia han estado veinte años de
hecho principalmente el de los eeuu han
estado veinte años dando en medias
verdades información falsa como lo
reveló hace unos meses el 'washington
post' y un libro reciente llama los
papeles de afganistán
que esto creó unas inercias en el cual
especialmente la gran mentira podríamos
decir era creer o querer creer que el
gobierno afgano podía resistir por un
ejército teóricamente formado un
ejército formado por eeuu teóricamente
con trescientos mil efectivos para dar a
los datos que están saliendo es que no
serían probablemente más de 50.000
efectivos vamos a ver si reales los que
podían combatir por otra parte era un
ejército sin ninguna convicción sin
ningún ideal frente al avance del
talibán o sea no no diría yo ni mucho
menos
todo lo que está pasando pero se han
guiado por una serie de información
creada por los mismos servicios de
inteligencia falsa y como digo medias
medias verdades medias mentiras que les
llevaron al convencimiento como dijeron
hace pocos días atrás de que el gobierno
afgano y el ejército afgano podía
aguantar entre seis meses hasta un año y
al final cayó en una semana
que se puede pronosticar para cuando
acabe la retirada de las tropas
extranjeras que pasará con afganistán
una vez que las potencias occidentales
salgan del país y que se deje de prestar
atención a la situación de esa nación ve
posibilidad de usted desde una relación
diplomática con el grupo extremista
no en el corto plazo y depende de quién
quiero decir rusia china y pakistán
a irán para hacer de alguna manera los
grandes sino grandes pero sí
considerables ganadores en esta partida
son países que van a establecer y ya
están manteniendo sus embajadas
aquí están siempre ha sido el que ha
apoyado el talibán
en china tiene ya grandes intereses en
este país que es un país clave que
políticamente rusia ya ha dicho que va a
establecer buenas relaciones e irán
tiene interés especialmente porque tiene
varios millones de afganos de las
guerras anteriores y de las de los
últimos 20 años los tienen como
refugiados en su territorio o sea otra
cosa es que relaciones van a tener con
occidente pues para tardar como va a
tardar el flujo de fondos que acaba de
cortar el fondo monetario internacional
yo creo que internamente va a ser un
periodo muy difícil un periodo en donde
probablemente el talibán tiene
experiencia de guerra pero tiene poca
experiencia de gobierno y al mismo
tiempo
digamos tiene fondos por parte por el
narcotráfico que controla y por todo lo
que es un sistema interno de impuestos
al movimiento de bienes dentro del país
pero esto solo no le va a alcanzar para
gestionar este país pero también como
está pasando ahora concilia
probablemente cuando sea plan que toda
esta situación y pasen unos meses poco a
poco también países occidentales
comenzarán pragmáticamente a establecer
relaciones a menos que los talibán sean
muy brutales en su represión sean muy
brutales y esto le impida de alguna
manera luego de la vergüenza que se está
pasando en este momento impida que
puedan restablecer relaciones mire muy
rápidamente joe biden sigue defendiendo
que la decisión correcta fue la de la
retirada se cumplió el objetivo de la
misión militar en afganistán pero que
tan golpeado queda el poderío
estadounidense en la escena
internacional
el objetivo o sea el objetivo que se
cumplió fue el primero de todos ese
plantear causas pies hace 20 años atrás
que fue que no hubiera ataques
terroristas desde al cadista pero
después eeuu si los gobiernos de eeuu
plantearon hacer lobby llama reconstruir
o construir el estado afgano ese ha sido
un fracaso absoluto y que eeuu debería
retirarse y creo que es un hecho que en
el cual por lo menos mucha gente estamos
de acuerdo con bay de la forma en que se
ha hecho la retirada es una vergüenza y
el perfecto desastre también por la
forma en que se amparó se protegió el
servicio como un paraguas a muchísima
gente y al desarrollo de una sociedad
civil dentro de afganistán
es incorrecto plantea vaivenes es una
también la media verdad una media
disculpe lo tengo que interrumpir nos
quedamos ya sin tiempo lamentablemente
pero gracias por toda la información y
en eeuu el huracán en henry de categoría
1 amenaza la costa este según el centro
nacional de huracanes con vientos de
hasta 120 kilómetros por hora el
fenómeno podría tocar tierra en las
próximas horas en long island o en las
costas de nueva inglaterra ante la
emergencia las autoridades de nueva york
que cancelaron este sábado un concierto
que reunía a grandes estrellas desde la
música en el central park
muchas caras de alegría se vieron en el
concierto en nueva york' los asistentes
presentaron su carné de vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 lo que les dio más seguridad
para estar en medio de la multitud a las
afueras las filas rodearon el central
park' la emoción se sentía en el
ambiente
me siento muy bien siento que la ciudad
se está abriendo tengo la vacuna y ahora
puedo estar en medio de la gente hay una
energía increíble y todo va a estar muy
bien
por la inclemencia del tiempo el
concierto no alcanzó a durar ni dos
horas y fue cancelado abruptamente en
medio de una actuación una tormenta
vinculada al huracán henri cubrió a
nueva york- que fue puesta en estado de
emergencia sin embargo el evento se
retomó un par de horas después el
alcalde de la ciudad había pedido a la
gente no salir de sus casas
queremos que haga sus planes de manera
correcta para minimizar la actividad del
domingo en la mayor medida posible
manténgase alejado de las carreteras y
que desee adentro habrá fuertes vientos
mucha lluvia y podríamos ver algunos
árboles cayendo necesitamos que la gente
esté segura así que lo digo ahora para
que pueda modificar sus planes
los neoyorquinos se enfrentan de nuevo
un fenómeno que recuerda al huracán
sandy en 2012 y que en su camino incluyó
las costas de nueva jersey y 9 aunque
está en la lista de los más mortíferos
en la historia de estados unidos provocó
147 muertes y daños por 65 mil millones
de dólares este sábado se cumplió una
semana desde que el terremoto de
magnitud de 7.2 devastó el suroeste de
haití las autoridades reportan 2.200
muertos 12.000 heridos y al menos 300
desaparecidos aunque las esperanzas de
encontrar vida entre las ruinas empiezan
a decaer el equipo internacional de
rescate de los topos mexicanos sigue
desempeñando su misión de búsqueda
informe de rosa pérez más dejo
en el cementerio de la localidad rural
de marcelino se celebran entierros de
muertes prematuras
[Música]
esta mañana miro a mi hija y mis nietos
con mucha tristeza solo dios puede
ayudarme siento mucho dolor
estoy en pie desde el sábado solo dios
puede ayudarme dios dame fuerza para
enterrarlos fue que sinde camine al
la esperanza empieza a desvanecerse los
equipos de búsqueda ya no captan señales
de vida entre las ruinas de los cayos
porque después de varias lecturas más
del equipo dejó de detectar fuimos para
no entrando hasta donde digamos a piso
hasta donde llegamos a piso y
desafortunadamente no hemos marcado
absolutamente nada
mientras en el campo de fútbol de los
cayos algunos supervivientes perdieron
incluso la fe de poder despedirse de sus
seres queridos mi hermano tenía 28 años
y murió ni siquiera encuentro su cuerpo
para poderlo enterrar más de 2.000
personas murieron entre las ruinas y más
de 100 mil casas quedaron destruidas el
estado de conmoción persiste sin embargo
la llegada de suministros empieza a
cubrir algunas necesidades básicas una
gestión organizada de la ayuda
internacional es el compromiso del
primer ministro ariel en río para
garantizar que las ayudas sean
utilizadas apropiadamente no como en el
terremoto de 2010 cuyas consecuencias
perduran 11 años después
y longás me he comprometido a ponerlo
todo en marcha para volver a encarrilar
mi país en una democracia funcional y
organizar lo antes posible elecciones
libres y transparentes
apoyadas por la comunidad internacional
y las autoridades locales las prometidas
elecciones se esperan como un primer
paso de salida de la crisis política
haitiana agravada tras el asesinato del
presidente joven el mois el 7 de julio
israel confirmó que sus aviones atacaron
a ubicaciones de hamás en la franja de
gaza- a última hora de este sábado en
una escalada de hostilidades después de
disparos transfronterizos en los que un
soldado judío y 41 palestinos acabaron
heridos el ejército israelí dijo que los
desórdenes fueron resultado de una
protesta en gas a cientos de palestinos
se reunieron cerca de la frontera
fuertemente fortificada de la franja y
algunos intentaron escalar la valla es
la mayor escalada de violencia desde el
conflicto de mayo que dejó 250
palestinos muertos y 13 israelíes
y después de las manifestaciones
arrestos y actos de violencia
registrados el sábado en varias ciudades
australianas durante protestas en contra
de los confinamientos el primer ministro
scott morrison defendió su política de
lucha contra la variante delta en el
país
estos residentes de cid le exigen
libertad pero las autoridades locales
los acusan de egoísmo el confinamiento
de la ciudad fue decretado a finales de
junio y debido al reciente aumento de
casos de kobe 19 se ha ampliado hasta
finales de septiembre
decenas de personas fueron detenidas
durante las manifestaciones del sábado
contra el encierro y cientos fueron
multadas por incumplir las órdenes de
salud pública a pesar de estas estrictas
medidas nuevas gales del sur cuya
capital es sídney registró el domingo
otro aumento récord de infecciones
informando de 830 nuevos casos y tres
muertes y que sus los casos en este
momento no están subiendo
exponencialmente subieron bastante en
los últimos días espero sólo en los dos
últimos días por supuesto han sido más
de 800
desde el comienzo de la pandemia
australia ha hecho frente a los brotes
imponiendo estrictos confinamientos
medidas que sólo en los dos últimos
meses han costado a la economía
17.000 millones de dólares australianos
en declaraciones a la televisión el
domingo el primer ministro scott
morrison defendió su política diciendo
que los confinamientos serían necesarios
hasta que el 70% de la población esté
vacunada hasta ahora sólo un 30% de los
mayores de 16 años andrés seguido las
dos vacunas pero el viernes se
administró el mayor número de dosis
hasta hoy
ayer fue otro día récord de vacunación
con más de 710.000 vacunas administradas
en todo australia
si se mantiene la actual tasa de
vacunación el 70% de los australianos
habrán sido completamente vacunados a
principios de noviembre
y así llegamos al final del informativo
siga con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com buenos días
[Música]
siga todas las noticias del deporte con
france24